[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I'm very excited
to have Professor Erika
Lee with us today to discuss
her widely acclaimed book,
"The Making of Asia American."
This book has been featured
in the "New York Times,"
"LA Times," and also
"The New Yorker."
Professor Lee, we
are really honored
for you to be here today.
And welcome home, and
welcome to Google.
And everyone please welcome
Professor Erika Lee.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIKA LEE: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much for coming.
You have to also
thank George and Amy.
They are very, very persistent.
They invited me to come out to
Google a couple of months ago,
I think.
And after several conversations,
they wore me down.
And here I am.
It's really a
pleasure to be here.
I'm going to start with
two different stories.
And it's also a little
bit of family history.
My family's history is
the story of America
as a nation of
immigrants, a country that
has welcomed immigrants
and helped them
achieve their American dreams.
From the beginning of the 19th
century through the beginning
of the 20th century,
the United States
welcomed over 3/5 of
the world's immigrants.
It remained the world's largest
immigrant-receiving country
during the 20th century.
Today, the United States
admits more immigrants
than any other
country, over a million
per year, which is about
20% of the world's migrants.
My grandfather,
[INAUDIBLE], was one
of the millions who came
to the United States
in the early 20th century.
He had been an orphan
struggling to make
ends meet as a farmer on a tiny
plot of land in southern China.
Generations of Lees had
farmed these rocky hills
in [INAUDIBLE]
Village right outside
of Guangzhou, southern China.
But by the early
1900s, Grandfather
told me he was killing
himself for nothing.
And he was not alone
in his struggle.
Entire villages in
the Pearl River Delta
of Guangdong Province emptied
out as working-age men
sought their futures elsewhere.
They went to
Southeast Asia, they
went to Australia, Canada,
Mexico, and the United States.
What the hell kind
of life I have,
Grandfather remembered thinking.
I suffer.
My eye is just looking
for a way to get out.
I want to live.
So I came to the United States.
He arrived in San
Francisco on June 30, 1918.
And life was a struggle.
He suffered and shuffled from
one low-paying job to another.
He worked as a domestic
servant in San Francisco
and also as a cook.
He perfected a
recipe for apple pie
when I was doing an oral
history with him in college.
He went on and on about how
good this apple pie was.
The secret, he told
me, is butter crust
with a little bit of lemon zest.
And another recipe
for roasted pork.
He followed a cousin
out to Philadelphia,
where the wages
were higher, and he
worked in a Chinese restaurant.
He saved up enough money
to return to China,
marry my grandmother, and
bring her over on a first class
steamship ticket.
They then moved to
Buffalo, New York,
where they worked day and
night in the restaurant
and also in laundries, all
while raising seven children.
Grandfather proudly became a
naturalized US citizen in 1946.
At a time when
the model minority
image of Asian
Americans was just
becoming part of
American popular culture,
my grandparents came to
represent the epitome
of American success.
My grandmother was even named
mother of the year in Buffalo
in the late 1950s.
Three sons became
doctors, one became
a dentist, another an engineer.
A daughter became a pharmacist
and another one an educator.
My grandparents loved America.
They were thankful for the
country that had allowed them
to live their American dreams.
And by the 1980s, my grandfather
was an unabashed supporter
of President Ronald Reagan
and his hope-filled vision
of America.
You could not enter their
house without passing
by this framed portrait
of President Reagan.
So that's one part of the story.
The other part is another
story, and that is America
as a nation of xenophobia.
My family's history is also the
story of American xenophobia
and its hatred of immigrants.
Anti-immigrant sentiment
and immigration restriction
have been a constant feature
of our American history.
Over the decades,
we have gradually
closed our doors to an
expanding number of immigrants--
the poor, the
disabled, those who
are considered
mentally inferior,
persons with suspect
morals, including
homosexuals, polygamists,
anarchist, Asians, and now
Muslims.
Today, only those with family
already in the United States
or those with needed
professional skills--
targeted as those with
exceptional ability--
can easily enter the country.
Otherwise, the
waiting time for many
is not just years
long, but decades long.
Those who somehow make
it into the United States
without documentation
or overstay their visas
are under constant threat
of arrest and deportation.
Since 2008, the
United States has
deported a record 3.8
million immigrants.
In 2016 alone, the United
States deported 240,000 people.
That same year, Donald
Trump was elected president
on a platform to build
the wall, deport millions
of undocumented immigrants, and
ban all Muslims from entering
the country.
My grandfather, [INAUDIBLE],
was unlucky enough
to try to immigrate
to the United States
during this high
point of xenophobia
when the US's Chinese Exclusion
Act was the law of the land.
This is a law that was passed
in 1882, May 6th, 1882.
We're actually getting ready to
recognize the 135th anniversary
of that law.
And this is a law that--
it was a temporary ban,
a temporary ban on
Chinese laborers.
It did still allow
certain exempt classes
to still come into
the United States--
merchants, teachers, travelers,
diplomats, and students.
But the vast majority of
Chinese-- mostly working
class and unskilled
laborers-- were banned.
This is the first
time in US history
that we've singled out an
immigrant group for exclusion
on the basis of their
race and their class.
So remember, my
grandfather is an orphan.
He's a farmer.
He is not a merchant.
He's not a student, a teacher,
traveler, or diplomat.
The only way for him
to enter the country
during the exclusion era is
to come with false papers.
He came under the
name of Yee Shew Ning.
You can see that on
his arrival certificate
here-- the son of a merchant who
was, in fact, not his father.
The Chinese refer to
immigrants like my grandfather
as paper sons.
Under law, he was
an illegal alien.
When interrogated by US
immigration officials
in San Francisco at the Angel
Island Immigration Station,
Grandfather was
asked 145 questions.
And his answers were
checked and rechecked
in cross-examinations
with his relatives.
How many rows in
your home village,
asked Inspector [? Hemstreit ?]
on July 10th, 1918.
Who lives in the third house
from the head of the village?
Give the names of husband,
wife, and children
who all live there.
He was also sent to the hospital
for a medical examination.
He was stripped naked, and
physicians meticulously
examined his teeth, his skin,
his hair, his sexual organs,
and his bones and
noted their findings
in his immigration file.
He was detained in the crowded
and unsanitary barracks
of the immigration
station for two weeks.
For the most part, his
answers, as part of those 145
different questions, matched
those of his paper father,
and grandfather was allowed
to enter the United States.
Before he left Angel
Island, however, he
was required to register
with the government.
He was issued what was called
a certificate of identity,
a form of identification
only required of Chinese
and Chinese-Americans
in the United States.
He was instructed to keep
it with him at all time,
because he might be
stopped on the street.
Immigration officials might
demand to see his papers.
And if he did not have them, he
could be arrested and deported.
In 1947, Grandfather became
a naturalized citizen.
This was important
for two reasons.
First, he was no longer
an illegal alien.
He benefited from a
pathway to citizenship
that was made possible when
President Franklin Delano
Roosevelt signed the repeal
of the Chinese Exclusion Act
in 1943.
The second reason
why this is important
is because he was able
to take back his name.
If you can see that
document up on the screen,
you can see that it says that
the petitioner is changing
his name from Shew Ning Yee,
his paper name, to Wallace Lee.
My grandfather is
quite a character.
He was very proud, of course,
to be in the United States.
But he wanted to be here
under his real name.
And so he told the judge, when
he was becoming naturalized,
that while they were doing
this whole American citizenship
thing, might we not
change my name to-- this
is very common for
immigrants when they're
becoming naturalized, to take
on an Americanized first name.
But he's changing his last
name, which is not as common.
And when the judge asked why,
my grandfather, of course,
did not say because I
came in with false papers
under this different name.
He said, Judge, I
have seven kids,
and the teacher makes
them sit alphabetically
in the classroom.
So they're all the
way in the back.
They can't see the board.
So I'm going to
change our last name--
maybe something in the middle
of the alphabet, like Lee.
That's the story he told,
and I don't doubt it.
Decades later, after he
became a naturalized citizen
in the 1980s, the president that
grandfather admired so much,
President Ronald Reagan,
would grant a pathway
to citizenship-- grant amnesty--
to over three
million undocumented
immigrants, mostly from
Mexico and Central America.
So I've just told two different
versions of the same family
history--
one that is very
uplifting and positive,
fulfilling America's promise
as a nation of immigrants,
but another that is a
little bit less positive,
one that focuses on closed
doors, gates, deportation,
registry, living
under false papers.
How do these two
stories fit together?
This is the history of
American immigration.
It's the story of
immigrant dreams turning
into American realities,
but it is also
a story of xenophobia and
immigrant scapegoating.
It's neither one or the other.
They coexist.
They intersect with each
other in a complicated way.
They both speak
truths about America,
and they work in
tandem together.
As a country, the
United States, we
have depended on immigration.
We have recruited immigrants.
We have welcomed them.
And we have also evacuated and
resettled refugees in need.
Yet throughout our history,
we have also banned many
immigrants-- the poor, the
illiterate, and entire groups--
based on their
nationality or religion.
We have established
an ideological test
for immigrant admission.
We have been slow to
answer the call of refugees
fleeing persecution.
We forcibly relocated
and incarcerated
120,000 Japanese-Americans
during World War
II on the mistaken basis
of military necessity,
or in today's language,
national security.
We have required certain
groups to register with the US
government so that we can
better track their movements
and keep them under
surveillance--
Chinese-Americans,
like my grandparents
in the early 20th century,
and Muslims 100 years later.
Our immigration laws have
not kept up with the times
and cannot flexibly respond
to changing labor and societal
needs.
As a result, we
have a long history
of undocumented immigration.
We have depended on the labor
of undocumented immigrants.
But when we don't
need them, we've
also deported them
in the millions,
sometimes under the guise
of voluntary repatriation,
sometimes by brutal force.
And those that are forced
to leave the country
include longtime
residents, US citizens,
and parents of US citizens.
I'm sure that we know that
history, that Ellis Island
history, of America's
welcome to immigrants.
That's something that is
taught in fourth grade,
and also in sixth grade, and
throughout our high school
years in the US.
But we know less about our
history of banning immigrants.
With the US debate
over immigration
at an all time high and
with drastic new changes
on every aspect of
immigration underway,
there's never been a
more important time
to explore this
forgotten history
and to consider what
it means for us today.
The history of Asian-Americans
that I write about
in "The Making of
Asian America" is
especially important
to understanding
these two different sides
of the United States.
Asian-Americans are an
extremely diverse conglomeration
of peoples who make up 23
different ethnic groups.
But together,
they've experienced
both the limits and the
possibilities of America.
So let's go back to that
nation of immigrants part
of the story one more time.
It can be argued that no
other group has represented
the vast complexity and scope
and diversity of immigration
to America than Asian-Americans.
Asians, for example,
have been recruited.
They have been brought.
They've been sent.
They've willingly gone.
They've married into.
They've been adopted into.
They've been accepted,
rejected, repatriated,
and deported from
the United States.
They have come as refugees,
as international students,
as undocumented immigrants
and picture brides as well as
high-tech workers.
In the mid 19th century up
through the mid 20th century,
Chinese, then Japanese, Koreans,
Filipinos, and South Asians
were recruited to help
build the United States.
They blasted through
mountains to build
the country's first
transcontinental railroad.
They mined for gold and silver.
They worked in the lumber
mills in the Pacific Northwest
and on the sugar
plantations in Hawaii.
They turned this
land that was once
barren into the
agricultural empire
that California is today.
And in the 20th century,
an even greater diversity
of Asian immigrants have come
to the United States as well.
Following World War
II, the United States
increased its presence
throughout Asia,
especially in places
like Japan and Korea,
as part of the Cold War.
As a result, new Asian
immigration journeys began.
[INAUDIBLE] Swartz married an
American soldier, left her home
in Okinawa in 1966.
That same year, [INAUDIBLE]
was adopted from Korea
and brought to Palo Alto, where
she grew up as Deann Borshay.
Deeann Borshay is now a
very well-known filmmaker
whose films on Korean adoption
are quite powerful and popular.
These new arrivals
married into or were
adopted into American
families and came
to represent a new
Asian America that
was less threatening,
able to become American,
and represented a
sign of more positive
US-Asian international
relations.
The aftermath of the
wars in Southeast Asia
sent 1.2 million Vietnamese Lao,
Hmong, and Cambodian refugees
to the United States
fleeing war and persecution.
130,000 Vietnamese were
evacuated from April
to December of 1975 alone.
That's a massive
humanitarian effort, 130,000
in those few short months.
We had not established a
concrete, centralized refugee
resettlement program before.
So the fact that we did
that in those months
is quite staggering.
A million more from
Vietnam, Laos, and Cambodia
fled on their own to
refugee camps in Thailand
and elsewhere over
the next few decades.
These are stories that we're
just beginning to know.
The trauma of war have kept
many of those stories hidden
within families.
They're slowly leaking out and
becoming more widely known.
I direct the only immigration
history research center
in the country.
It's at the University
of Minnesota.
And we've been working
for several years
to try to preserve the
histories of the communities
around us, but also of the most
recent immigrants and refugees.
To do this, we decided
to do something
different than the
traditional oral history
where we come with a
clipboard and ask questions.
We wanted to give the power
of storytelling to immigrants
and refugees themselves.
I know I'm at a tech
company, and it's
a little awkward for a historian
to be pitching a tech idea.
But we just launched this
wonderful digital storytelling
website last week.
It's a place where anyone
can write, create, and edit
their own digital story and
submit it to our collection
to be publicly accessible.
We started out with
just a few stories.
We were especially interested
in documenting and preserving
the histories of the elder
Southeast Asian refugees
in the Twin Cities.
We now have 215 stories
representing over 50 groups.
And there is one story
from the community
that I especially feel connected
to, and that is [INAUDIBLE].
She is a Mong refugee whose
family were closely allied
with American soldiers in Laos.
In fact, her family
not only fought
on behalf of the United States
during the so-called Secret
War, during the wars
in Southeast Asia,
but also, her family,
on numerous occasions,
helped to rescue
downed American pilots
after they had crashed in the
area where they were living.
Because of that alliance
with the United States,
after the Lao government
fell and became communists,
the [? Zhangs ?] were
targeted for persecution.
And so they had to
flee their homeland.
And she spent the next 20
years in a refugee camp waiting
to come to the United States.
She's older now.
She has not told
her story that much.
But when we talked to her, she
felt extremely enthusiastic
that someone was willing
to ask and that we
were going to preserve
that story-- not
only for her children
and grandchildren,
but also for the greater public.
So you can see she came
to our interview session
with photographs and the
[INAUDIBLE] that she had sewn.
But the thing that really
struck me about her story
was how important and timely
it was to preserve them.
She said, I'm over 60 now.
If I don't share this
with you, it will die,
and no one will know.
So these are the
stories that are
going to continue to help
us understand, again,
America's relationship
to immigration
and the ways in which we
have fulfilled our promise
as a nation of immigrants.
Another part of that story
is the 1965 Immigration Act,
passed almost exactly 50
years ago last October.
This law ushered in
the greatest numbers
of new Asian immigrants,
14.7 million since 1965.
This act, signed by President
Johnson on Liberty Island
with the Statue of
Liberty behind him,
was a hallmark of the
Civil Rights Movement
as well as a strong diplomatic
statement during the Cold War.
We were just ending a period of
great immigration restriction.
We had discriminatory
immigration quotas.
And during the Cold
War, as we were
trying to spread this message
that American democracy,
freedom, and capitalism is
superior than Soviet communism,
that discrimination in
our immigration laws
was a constant sign
of our hypocrisy.
And it was used against
us in many ways.
So Johnson signed
this law not only as
a measure of
international diplomacy,
but also to respond to the
American Civil Rights Movement
that was happening within
our borders as well.
What has happened
since '65 is that now,
our system of immigration is
based on family reunification
and on professional skills.
This is still the system
that remains in place.
For Asian-Americans, this has
meant a major transformation
in American society with record
levels of new immigration.
One of the most important
shifts is, as you can see,
a historic shift away from
immigration from Europe
to immigration from
Latin America and Asia.
The post-1965 pathways
to the United States
have been especially important
to perspective Asian immigrants
from places like
Taiwan, India, Korea,
and more recently,
China, places that
have increased
educational attainment
but whose economies have not
kept up with the new educated
population.
Seeking better
economic opportunities,
many of these high-skilled and
highly-educated professionals
have come to the United States.
In fact, it can be argued that
no other group has benefited
more from these recent
changes in immigration laws
than Asian immigrants
and Asian-Americans.
In 1960, the total
Asian-American population
was just under 1 million
people, or about 1%
of the total US population.
Since then, Asian immigration
to the United States
has grown exponentially.
And it is increasingly diverse.
The 21 million Asian-Americans
now in the United States
make up over 6.5% of
the total US population.
Between 2000 and 2010, the
Asian-American population
increased by a
staggering 46%, making
them the fastest-growing
group in the country.
And they're part of America's
larger transformation
from into a majority
minority country,
estimated to be around
2044 with an increase
of 130% in the coming decades.
Asian immigrants
receive about 3/4
of the H-1B visas granted to
highly skilled guest workers,
including Indians.
Like what I'm doing here?
Sundar Pichai now leads some of
the biggest high-tech companies
in the country, like Google.
And Chinese are now the
single largest group
of international students
coming into the country.
So the face of new immigration
to the United States is Asian.
And many of these new
immigrants' experiences
reflect the US's welcome
and its enduring history
of a nation as immigrants.
Recent reports predict
that Asian immigrants
will be the largest
immigrant group in the US,
surpassing Hispanics.
They're settling in places
that have traditionally
welcomed immigrants, like New
York and San Francisco and LA.
But they're also in places where
such new immigration is new--
Las Vegas, Charleston,
Houston, Phoenix,
and Minneanapolis St. Paul.
Along with Latinos,
Asian-Americans
are transforming
the United States.
So that's the nation
of immigrants story.
It runs through the
history of Asian-Americans.
They intersect with each other.
It remains true today.
But the other side is also
part of the story as well.
As today's headlines bring news
of deportation raids, President
Trump's executive orders, a
halt to the refugee resettlement
program, and the travel ban
on non-citizens from now
six majority-Muslim
countries, we
know that Asian-Americans
have been part of this story
as well.
Before the US tried to institute
a travel ban on Muslims,
we banned Asians.
Before we focused on the
so-called Mexican illegal
immigration problem,
we patrolled the border
and raided cities in the
search for undocumented Chinese
immigrants.
The first border patrol agents
along the US-Mexico border
in the early 1900s called
themselves Chinese catchers.
In fact, Asian immigrants
were amongst the most reviled,
feared, and hated in US history.
This is an early 20th-century
advertisement for soap.
This is how widespread the image
of the despised Chinese laborer
was, that it would be put
on a package for soap.
Asians were valued as laborers.
But soon after their arrival
in the United States,
they became targets of massive
anti-immigrant sentiment,
a xenophobia that was
inextricably connected
to the already
racial discrimination
that African-Americans, American
Indians, and Mexicans faced
in the United States.
They were treated as peoples
unfit for US citizenship
and as outsiders to
American society.
They were barred from
becoming naturalized citizens,
prohibited from owning
or leasing land,
and marrying whites
in some states.
They were harassed,
driven out and segregated
from the rest of America.
This is a cartoon
that was published
in 1881 in a San Francisco
illustrated magazine called
"The Wasp."
And for many, many
decades, San Franciscans
had been trying to convince
their fellow citizens
on the East Coast that Chinese
immigration was a huge problem,
and that if we did not act,
the country would be invaded,
overrun by the teeming
millions of Chinese,
this despised, undesirable
immigrant population.
And in this cartoon, you can see
that what the Californians are
trying to say is you
on the East Coast,
you have the Statue of
Liberty, the one that
is welcoming the right kind
of immigrants from Europe.
On the West Coast,
we have this statue,
this statue for our harbor.
And instead of a woman
representing equality, freedom,
and democracy, we have
this Chinese coolie labor.
He is wearing bedraggled Robes
he's got a rat-tail-like queue.
He's an unassimilable foreigner.
And he's bringing, as
the rays of light show
emanating from his head--
he's bringing filth and
immorality, disease,
and ruin to white labor.
He's also holding an opium
pipe in his left hand,
and he's resting
on a human skull.
So Chinese immigration
represents the destruction
not only of everything
that we hold dear,
but American
civilization itself.
By the 1880s, the debate
over Chinese immigration
had become nationwide.
On February 28th,
1882, as Congress
is debating this ban
on Chinese laborers,
Senator John Miller
of California
introduced in the
United States this bill
to exclude Chinese
immigrant laborers.
The California Republican
spelled out the imminent danger
that Chinese immigration
posed, including
the fact that
according to Miller,
Chinese immigrants were, quote,
a degraded and inferior race.
Chinese immigrants
competed with white workers
with their, quote, machine-like
ways and their muscles of iron.
Miller proclaimed that a
vote for Chinese Exclusion
was a vote for both white
labor and for the public good
of the country.
Public good.
I want you to keep that in mind.
The Chinese Exclusion Act became
law on May 6th, 1882, and marks
the first time
that we've singled
out a group for exclusion
based on race and class.
Part of the story of
Chinese immigration
during the exclusion
era takes place
at the Angel Island
Immigration Station
right in San Francisco Bay.
Open from 1910 to
1940, it processed over
1 million immigrants from
over 80 different Countries
on their way into and
out of the United States.
It's especially important
for Chinese immigrants who
are coming, because
this is a place that
was designed to
enforce the Chinese,
and then later, other
Asian exclusion laws.
So instead of being processed
through Ellis Island,
like so many European
immigrants were,
the immigrants who came
through Angel Island
countered their detention time
in weeks rather than hours.
They experienced the invasive
medical examinations,
the grueling interrogations,
and they also
were detained in immigrant
barracks that were overcrowded,
unsanitary, and were more like
prisons than anything else.
The policies that were put
in place of Angel Island laid
the foundation for how we
would process immigrants--
not just Chinese,
but all immigrants--
through the 20th century.
Once admitted into the
United States, for example,
Chinese immigrants
were still suspect
and were placed
under surveillance
wherever they went.
This is a page from a California
immigration official's journal.
He's based in
Downieville, California.
And he's keeping track of
every Chinese immigrant who
is within his town.
As you can see, he's got
their photographs, their age,
their name, any physical
marks, and whether they're
in the country or
if they've left.
Chinese immigrants
were also required
to mandatory registration
with the government.
This is one of the
certificates of identity
that my grandfather had
to apply for as well.
And it wasn't just
Chinese immigrants.
It was also required
of Chinese Americans
born in the United States.
This is racial profiling.
This is the
certificate of identity
for a very well-known actress
in the early 20th century, Anna
May Wong.
Some of you may know that name.
She is really the only
Asian-American actor or actress
who was a Hollywood star.
Now, she was only
allowed to play roles
like Fu-Manchu's daughter,
the evil oriental overlord's
suffering daughter.
But she was a
well-known presence.
But even she, whose face was
so commonly known, so famous
around the world, had to carry
one of these certificates
of identity as well.
The Chinese Exclusion
Act was just
the beginning of a
decades-long movement
to exclude all Asian immigrants.
Given President Trump's
recent executive order,
the 1917 Immigration Act
is especially noteworthy.
The act involved
several provisions,
including a literacy test for
all prospective immigrants.
But the act also
identified a region
that Congress called the
Asiatic Barred Zone, from which
all immigrants were prohibited.
So what this meant
was that immigrants
from almost the
entire Asian continent
were prohibited from
entering the United States.
In addition to
China, Japan, Korea,
the zone included
India, Siam, Indochina,
parts of Siberia,
Afghanistan, and Arabia,
the islands of Java, Sumatra,
Ceylon, Borneo, New Guinea,
[INAUDIBLE], and
various lesser groups
with a total population
band of over 500 million.
The law was in
effect until 1952.
The 1917 act was built on a
series of Asian exclusion laws.
As you can see, we're barring
an expanding number of groups,
not only of general
immigration laws barring groups
like idiots and
lunatics and poppers,
but also every single
Asian immigrant group,
until we get to the
1924 Immigration Act,
when, in addition to the
restrictions and bans placed
on Asians by the 1917 act,
we ban all Asians completely.
This is followed by restrictions
on Southern and Eastern
European immigration as
well as mass deportations
of Mexican immigrants
and Mexican-Americans
during the 1930s.
Anti-Asian sentiment
peaks during World War II
with many Americans, led by
politicians and the media,
believing that
Japanese-Americans represented
a national security
threat, that they could not
be trusted, that despite
outward appearances
and claims of loyalty
to the United States,
they were, in fact, working
for the Japanese Empire.
Does anyone recognize the
artist behind this cartoon?
Dr. Seuss was very prolific
during the early 20th century.
He created a lot of cartoons
during World War II,
many of which had an
anti-Japanese bent.
And in this one, called "Waiting
for the Signal from Home,"
you can see masses of
Japanese-Americans, all up
and down the West
Coast, who are,
on outside appearances,
perfectly assimilated.
They're wearing Western suits.
But they also all look the same.
You can't distinguish
one from the other.
And it's clear that once
that signal comes from home,
they will be called
to action and called
to destroy the United States
with dynamite from within.
These are common perceptions
of Japanese-Americans
during the war.
And on February 19th, 1942,
almost exactly 75 years ago,
President Franklin Roosevelt
signed an executive order
requiring the mass
removal of all persons
of Japanese ancestry
from the West Coast.
This executive order, which
was not put before Congress,
directed the Secretary of War
and other military commanders
to identify certain
military areas,
certain sensitive
military zones,
and gave them the power to
expel anyone from those areas.
Placing the responsibility
with the military,
this executive order--
Executive Order 9066-- used the
premise of military necessity
or national security that
allowed the government
to round up and expel
entire communities
without compensation
and without due process
or proof of wrongdoing.
Japanese-Americans were
never listed by name
in Executive Order 9066.
But discriminatory intent was
clear from previous government
actions and statements
by officials.
If you're following
any of the news
around the legal challenges
to the executive orders,
this language of
discriminatory intent
is one of the foundations that
the cases are resting upon--
that the travel ban
is a Muslim ban based
on discriminatory intent,
based on previous statements
by President Trump
and other officials.
So they're not listed
in the executive order,
but we know from officials
that Japanese-Americans
were the targets.
For example, Lieutenant
General John Dewitt,
head of the newly created
Western Defense Command,
is in charge of defending
the entire West Coast.
He consistently
and publicly stated
that, quote, the Japanese
race was an enemy race.
I have no confidence in
their loyalty whatsoever,
he wrote in January of 1942.
Racial affinities are
not severed by migration.
It makes no difference whether
he is an American citizen.
He is still Japanese.
Thus, in his reckoning,
American born Japanese
remained, quote, potential
enemies at large.
Or, in other words,
a Jap is a Jap.
Within weeks of Executive
Order 9066 being signed,
the US government began
what it euphemistically
called evacuation.
On March 1st, 1942,
General Dewitt
issued the first
public proclamation
officially notifying all
persons of Japanese ancestry
that they were to be removed
and evacuated from, or excluded,
from the Western parts of
Washington state, California,
Oregon, and parts of Arizona.
A curfew was also put
into place requiring
all persons of Japanese
ancestry to remain at home
from the hours of
8:00 PM to 6:00 AM.
Once an exclusion
order was issued,
residents were generally
given just one week
to prepare themselves
for removal.
They were allowed to
bring with them only what
they could carry.
Families were rushed to sell
stores, cars, farm equipment,
farms, furniture,
clothes, valuables,
often at huge losses.
On the designated
evacuation days,
all persons of Japanese
ancestry within specific zones
were ordered to assemble
at central locations
where they were met
by armed US soldiers.
You guys know the Tanforan
Mall in San Bruno, right?
Do you know that it used to be
the Tanforan Racetrack or horse
track?
And the Tanforan horse track
was the gathering point,
the evacuation center
for Japanese-Americans
in the Bay Area.
Each individual wore
a US government-issued
identification tag.
They were given these tags.
They were sent with
all of their belongings
to places like the
Tanforan Racetrack, which
had only recently been cleared
of its former inmates, i.e.
horses.
So Japanese-Americans were
placed in the horse stalls that
had still the remnants
of what horses
do in their horse stalls.
It was extremely humiliating.
Once assembled,
Japanese-American evacuees
were transported to 16
hastily-erected assembly
centers in California, Oregon,
Washington, and Arizona.
These new homes were hastily
refurbished fairgrounds
or racetracks where
the inmates were kept
in former stalls and barracks.
Barbed wire fences, and guard
towers surrounded the centers.
120,000 individuals-- 2/3--
2/3 of them American citizens,
children, school-age children--
were forced to leave school,
abandon their businesses
and homes, and were uprooted
from their communities.
There were no individual
hearings or trials.
They were vilified as a group.
They were relocated to camps
unfit for human habitation
and incarcerated for
the duration of the war.
Not one Japanese-American
was ever charged or convicted
of espionage.
It would take
decades of activism,
investigative
research, and lobbying.
But in 1976, President
Gerald Ford officially
declared the wartime
removal and relocation
of Japanese Americans a tragedy.
In 1982, the Commission
of Wartime Incarceration
issued a final report
and a scathing rebut
of the government's actions.
Executive Order 9066,
it wrote, was not
justified by military necessity.
Instead, race
prejudice, war hysteria,
and a failure of
political leadership
led to an egregious policy.
A grave injustice was done to
American citizens and resident
nationals of Japanese ancestry,
the commission concluded.
In 1988, the Civil Liberties
Act was approved by Congress
and signed into law
by President Reagan.
The act authorized,
among other things,
a formal US apology for
removal and incarceration.
We could end on that note--
a recognition of a historical
injustice and reparations
and a coming to our senses about
what we've done in the past
and how we should never
repeat that again.
But unfortunately, 13 years
after that law was signed,
the tragic attacks on
the World Trade Center
and the Pentagon on
September 11th, 2001,
and the United States'
ongoing global war on terror,
ushered a new wave of
xenophobia and prejudice
reminiscent of the
post-Pearl Harbor treatment
of Japanese-Americans.
In the search for perpetrators,
entire Middle Eastern,
South Asian, and Muslim
immigrant communities
were made vulnerable to blanket
racially motivated charges
that they were
either terrorists,
potential terrorists, or
terrorist sympathizers.
Racial profiling, heightened
government scrutiny,
deportation, and hate crimes
all increased dramatically.
Within days of the attacks,
law enforcement officials
had arrested more
than 1,200 people,
only a handful of
whom were proven
to have any links to terrorism.
Reflecting the
United States' belief
that Pakistan, for example,
was a national security
risk, as a terrorist
feeder state, almost 40%
of the detainees
arrested were believed
to be Pakistani nationals.
Like Japanese immigrants
taken into custody
after the attack
of Pearl Harbor,
Muslim men began to
disappear from their families
and communities.
Mandatory registration
with the government
was put into effect for all
non-citizen men, 16 years
or older, from 25 predominantly
Muslim countries and North
Korea.
So when you hear this
talk of no Muslim ban,
you should be aware
that we've been-- sorry,
no Muslim registry-- you should
be aware that we have been
registering Muslims since 2001.
This system, known as the
National Security Entry Exit
Registration System,
was only just ended
before President
Obama left office.
Over 85,000 people registered.
14,000 were found to be
out of immigration status
and were placed into
deportation proceedings.
Zero were found to be convicted
of terror-related activities.
Still, many Arab-American,
Muslim, and South
Asian-American
communities continue
to be treated as if they were
already guilty or disloyal
to the United States.
In the weeks and months
following the terrorist attacks
on 9/11, hate crimes directed
at all of these groups increased
by 1,600%.
And the trend has
continued in recent years.
In just the past three weeks,
three Indian immigrants
have been shot, two of
them fatally, in incidents
that investigators are
considering as hate crimes.
Computer software engineer
Srinivas Kuchibhotla
was fatally shot in
Kansas on February 20th.
Store owner Harnisch Patel
was killed in South Carolina.
Deep Rai was shot in front of
his house outside of Seattle
after an attacker shouted
go back to your country.
During the divisive 2016
presidential election,
anti-Muslim assaults rose
to their highest levels
since 2001.
And we know that so
many of the candidates
called for either a
total ban on Muslims
or for surveillance
of Muslim communities.
The FBI has reported 257
incidents of anti-Muslim hate
crimes in 2015, a 67% increase
from the previous year.
The Southern Poverty Law
Center reported more than 30
in the first five days after
the presidential election.
Today, we're in the
midst of a brand
new debate over immigration.
During his first
two weeks in office,
President Trump signed
three executive orders.
I know you know about them.
First were two orders on
immigration and border
security, which included
actions on his campaign
promises to build that wall
and to step up deportations
and immigration enforcement.
The Border and
Enhancing Public Safety
in the Interior
executive order also
calls for the additional hiring
of 10,000 immigration officers,
increased immigrant
detention, increased removal
of undocumented immigrants,
stripping federal funding
to so-called sanctuary
cities, levying sanctions
against recalcitrant
countries who will not
cooperate with the United
States' immigration deportation
orders, and publicizing
crimes committed
by undocumented immigrants.
On January 27th, President
Trump signed an executive order
that indefinitely
suspended the resettlement
of Syrian refugees, paused the
overall refugee resettlement
program, temporarily
banned non-citizens
from seven majority
Muslim nations.
This law, as we all
know, was the subject
of massive national
protests at airports
as well as numerous
legal challenges.
It was temporarily blocked.
The president signed, last
week, a new order that
supersedes the original one.
It no longer bans
immigrants from Iraq.
And the Syrian Refugee
Resettlement Program
is not singled out for
indefinite detention.
Green card holders
are also exempt.
But all of the other aspects
of that ban are still in place.
So what does this mean
for Asian-Americans?
For many of us, these
actions remind us
of older policies and
government actions that
separated our families,
devastated our communities,
and disregarded
the Constitution.
The Chinese Exclusion Act
and Executive Order 9066
were presented as measures for
the public good and military
necessity, when
really, such laws were
a cloak for discrimination.
For me personally, it
frustrates me and angers me
to no end to realize
that we are repeating
these mistakes of the past--
mistakes that so many
of our former leaders
came to apologize for or came
to regard as historic mistakes
that should not be repeated.
But what is happening
today is not
just about what happened
to us in the past.
It's imperative to remember that
these actions directly impact
Asian-Americans today as well.
Asians are the
fastest-growing group
of undocumented immigrants.
Since 1990, for
example, the number
of undocumented immigrants
from India grew by 300%,
from South Korea by
250%, from China by 150%.
In California alone, 16% of
all undocumented immigrants
are Asian-American.
So the time to act is now.
When we're thinking about
our long history of not only
what was done to us, but
also what we did in response,
we should remember this
man, Fred Korematsu.
He refused to comply
with executive Order 9066
in San Leandro, which is
where his family was living
and ran a nursery.
When his family went
to the assembly center,
he stayed behind.
He was hiding out in San
Leandro until May of 1942,
and officials arrested him
and sent him to prison.
The ACLU came to his defense.
Ernest Bessig, a
lawyer for the ACLU,
approached Korematsu
and asked him
whether he'd be willing
to put his case forward
as a test case to consider
whether the executive order was
constitutional or not.
Korematsu agreed.
As he explained later,
I didn't feel guilty,
because I didn't
do anything wrong.
Every day in school, we
said the pledge of the flag
with liberty and
justice for all,
and I believed all of that.
I was an American citizen,
and I had as many rights
as anyone else.
A federal district
court did not agree.
It convicted Korematsu of
defying the military orders.
And in September of
1943, he was forced
to move to a camp in Utah.
From within the camp, Korematsu
continued his legal battle,
and the case went all the
way to the US Supreme Court.
In December of 1944, the
court issued its ruling.
A majority of justices
upheld the constitutionality
of incarceration of
Japanese-Americans.
Justice Hugo Black,
a former member
of the Ku Klux Klan in Alabama,
delivered the court's opinion.
The high court accepted
the Army's position
that removal and incarceration
of Japanese-Americans
was a military necessity,
and in essence,
justified bowing to military
demands during a time of war.
This ruling still stands
as legal precedent.
After 9/11, Korematsu
was an outspoken critic
of the US government's
national security measures
and warned that they were
reminiscent of civil liberties
violations in the past.
Even in times of
crisis, he wrote,
we must guard against
prejudice and keep
uppermost our commitment
to law and justice.
For Korematsu, this was about
civil rights for all Americans
and human rights for all.
No one should ever
be locked away simply
because they share the same
race, ethnicity, or religion
as a spy or terrorist.
If that principle
was not learned
from the internment
of Japanese-Americans,
then these are
very, very dangerous
times for our democracy.
Today, Asian-Americans
are recognizing
that they have a
special responsibility
to speak out against these hate
crimes, growing xenophobia,
and anti-Muslim rhetoric.
Just a few weeks ago
on February 19th,
the 75th anniversary of the
signing of Executive Order
9066, dozens of Day
of Remembrance events
took place across the country.
In the wake of
deportation raids,
the travel ban, the end to the
refugee resettlement program,
many were asking
could it happen again.
It already is was the
answer from many corners.
Some Japanese-American
organizations
went even further than
the traditional day
of remembrance
activities and called
on direct acts of solidarity
with Muslim-Americans.
I attended the Day
of Remembrance event
in St. Paul, Minnesota.
And there, the Japanese-American
Citizens League and the Council
of American-Islamic
Relations for Minnesota
came together to read
a joint statement.
These two communities
were important.
One had suffered through
racial discrimination
and incarceration
during World War II.
The other, whose members
include the largest
Somali-American population
in the United States,
are being racially profiled
and religiously profiled today.
Came together and closed
the events with these words.
"The legally sanctioned
discrimination
targeting Americans
of Japanese descent
during the World
War II era mirrors
the current
demonization of Muslims
and the governmental
legitimization of Islamophobia
through executive orders
and proposed legislation
targeting Muslims.
While Japanese-American and
American Muslim histories
and experiences
are not identical,
we share in a common
and parallel struggle
in seeking a just
and inclusive future.
We will resist, oppose,
defy, and intervene
in any and all acts of
racism, xenophobia, misogyny,
Islamophobia, and
oppression targeting
our own or other marginalized
and oppressed communities.
These words and
statements of solidarity
could not be more timely.
They remind us that
Asian-American history
offers more than just
lessons of the past.
It's a call to action.
Our history of being welcomed
into as well as rejected
from the United States
requires us to stand up,
to speak up, and act up today
as more immigrants are targeted
once again.
This is the time to insist
that our history matters,
and to proclaim never again.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you
so much, Erika Lee,
for providing historical
context, your family history,
as well as calling for action
in contemporary society.
AUDIENCE: But just wanted to ask
one question before we wrap up.
This one got a lot of votes.
How can we help spread awareness
of the different challenges
faced by highly educated
East/South Asian communities
versus Southeast
Asian communities,
Hmong Cambodian, which may face
different educational economic
experiences.
ERIKA LEE: So one of the things
I mentioned earlier before is
how diverse the
Asian-American community is--
23 different groups.
And of course, that
diversity is not only
based on ethnicity, national
origin, immigration status,
generation, class,
education, as well.
And I know you have a
program later this week
on battling that image
of the model minority.
One of the challenges
is lumping everybody
into that model
minority stereotype
and how that disadvantages
groups who are still struggling
economically and also to achieve
and have equal access to higher
education.
I think that one of the
situations where we are today--
this rise in hate crimes and
this demonization of people
who either are immigrants
or look like they don't
belong in the United States--
kind of erases this
idea that class
and education and
professional status
can protect us from xenophobia.
This murder of the computer
software engineer in Kansas
is just one example.
The epithets, go back
to your own country,
is another example.
People are seeing just race
or perceived religious status.
They're not looking for your
diploma or your employee ID
card.
This is a time--
and I think we've experienced
this over the past 15,
16 years or so--
where many, many groups of
Asian-Americans-- again,
regardless of class status
or national origin--
are being targeted
under xenophobia.
So I think to better
understand, again,
what is happening
in the wider world
and how this really
is impacting a larger
group of Asian-Americans is
one first step towards that.
SPEAKER: Thank you so
much for being here.
[APPLAUSE]